so if that girl is 350 and this one is a
hundred thousand-plus ahold a hail cute
this is this world it's real absolutely
it's one of our customers actually one
of you guys did that
yeah laid him out that's right
[Music]
hi welcome to Pacific supporting arts in
Jordan nice to meet you hi how you going
to change man I saw me you nice to meet
you bro I have a Krieger hunting shotgun
right here what how old is this right
this rifles maybe 10 years old oh so
it's not like it seems like it's so
empty so this is what's called Turkish
walnut if you can see it comes from
Turkey see all this burl here all this
colors in Turkey you can to Turkey
twenty five thousand nine ninety five
[Music]
it's ready to go
my daddy left me in 12 days when you pay
us but there's nothing oh do you see
that oh you see that what made you get
into this stuff sure I've been shooting
all my life ever in effect yeah
so I just kind of are all into it over
here what in the world is this right
here Pro I mean it just looks like a
terminator whip with this this is an on
shoots 22 target rifle on shows this is
what they use in the Olympics this is
the little 22 single-shot rifle so these
guys they shoot in different positions
right and they're shooting targets that
are size of Lincoln's I penny you know
at some times 50 meters so you need
absolutely the best most precision
equipment to achieve that and that's
what this is that's why everything's so
heavy you can see how heavy it really is
just shoulder here yeah and adjust for
your shoulder and then the height of
your face on the stock right here yeah
I shoot sometime obviously right I have
a little property in the south and I
found it better to do it between Brooks
keeps your body nice and steady do you
know if [ __ ] hibbett is gonna just
yeah and sometimes they'll hold it for a
half an hour 45 minutes that's a workout
trapping what you think yeah okay cool
what else you got
alright so over here this is what really
defines us as the most premier gun
dealer in the United States
what's the name of that show we shot and
missed and struck all what's the name
that Oh Beverly Hillbillies is that what
the damn gun eviews right no not at all
what is this is a Beretta so this
company has been in business since 1526
1526 they were making gun that's right
century go ahead and take a look this
guns 110 thousand dollars just one part
of the price of this gun is the price of
the engraving professor upon the
artistry that goes into it this gun took
over two years so great yeah this dog
has a damn duck in his mouth and it says
made in Italy so the owner then shot the
duck and and trap you brought and bag
this is the most expensive gun I've ever
seen if you like all this I've got
something really interesting for you to
look at over there that's very this is
part of a four gun set this is three
hundred and fifty four thousand dollars
the majority the people that buy these
guns are rich as white people
you'd be surprised you buys these guys
as a matter of fact you say it comes
with four more guns or use three more
guns in this set you show them what you
mean like a handgun no it's blowing a
matching set of four different guns
so there's a 12 and 20 and 28 and a 410
each a different size in a different
caliber it's got the game scenes here
with birds and then the scrolls and it's
all done by hand is that a bear it's
actually it's just a different kind of
hunting dog this thing has John Wayne
would be proud for hey okay trap me see
something like see anything you like
trap me which one you like what color
which engravement I must have smoked a
bit of gunpowder that's what you gotta
be on to spend $300,000 I wanted em damn
rifles John Wayne didn't shoot I saw
some reasonable ones but $100,000 I mean
the engravement was really it was
advanced it was another level it was
some stuff that looked like a
masterpiece I cannot even lie they had
dogs and bears carrying ducks and quails
so I can see that but honestly if you
plan on hunting being a gun collector
what you spent over $300,000 for that
Webb